3 2 1 0 bonjour à tous vous entrez dans
le studio troisième séance
d'enregistrement pour aller aux bottes
thomas la directrice de cabinet de
voisins-le-bretonneux donnent de la voix
depuis janvier pour informer les
habitants un format à retrouver sur le
site internet de la ville chaque mois
vous impliquer et en savoir plus aux
deux cas c'est encore une autre façon de
communiquer toujours de l'oral
et on sait quelque chose qui ont qui est
facile à écouter puisqu'on peut là on
peut l'emmener avec soin dans le train
sur son trajet pour aller au travail par
exemple
et donc c'est un format court et simple
pour donner un maximum d'informations
au sommaire ce mois ci du jardinage avec
les agents des espaces verts de la ville
des découvertes enregistrées aussi sur
le terrain pour ce mois de mars à
lisbonne thomas fait partager le
quotidien et la passion de frédéric des
espaces verts de la commune pour faire
découvrir les métiers des agents de la
ville parce que je pense que les chinois
ne connaissent pas bien ne se rendent
pas vraiment compte eh bien on va sur le
terrain
c'est sur le terrain qu'on voit là qu'on
sent les choses qu'on ressent les choses
et que la personne qui va nous répondre
là j'en ai mais il sera beaucoup plus
impliqués et il nous racontera vraiment
son métier le numéro de mars est en
cours de montage 10 minutes à retrouver
bientôt sur le site internet de la ville
et ses réseaux sociaux